joining me now is Ari Fleischer former
White House press secretary Fox News
contributor also with me is tom Fitton
president of judicial watch re looking
at trump's legal team what's your take
away
well there are superstars but are they
superstars who will work well together
and divide the labor appropriately
that's the real question there certainly
have been great names legal names they
each have storied histories but you know
a lot of this work too is the legwork
getting information on witnesses to poke
holes and witness testimony in case
those witnesses are called that's a lot
of hard work that's going to have to be
done in a short amount of time well I
think they've divided it up witnessed by
witness and argument by argument from
the constitutional to the fact-based
arguments so I think that's already in a
process tom Fitton what we've heard from
the media are Cipollone is not a he's
not a media person he's not done a lot
of you know sexy trial work and so
they're trying to like I guess raise
expectations lower expectations for him
but I love the fact and you know full
disclosure he's a close friend of mine
so I know he's gonna be fantastic but I
love the fact that he's kind of an
enigma to them because he's not someone
who seeks the limelight well any basic
research into his background he's an
experienced attorney my guess is he can
handle politicians in the Senate and
that process you can see though why
Nancy Pelosi didn't want the Senate
trial to happen and that's why she
obstructed it because now you're gonna
have all these politicians that they
have pointed as impeachment managers
come over and have to deal with real
lawyers I fear we're gonna have a
Cavanaugh type situation because in the
ordinary course the president's going to
be vindicated in short order so they're
gonna think of ways to subvert that this
is why your motion for dismissal is a
good idea this is why they should not
ship out because he's conflicted he's a
witness and they should also consider
doing pulmonary hearings outside of a
full Senate trial to kind of litigate
these issues about prosecutorial
misconduct about what shifted the Senate
should already be doing these types of
hearing that's Paul hunt why does can't
Lindsey Graham a call hunter Biden if
they really want this in a separate
hearing I mean they're not gonna do it
till after it
Pietschmann but these are questions that
we've been asking and an re by the way
Democrat Senator Jeff Merkley thinks
anyone to bias to be a juror should step
aside they're going to have to search
their heart and ask if they're able to
set aside their preconceptions all of us
all hundred of us and if we are unable
to do that if we're unable to in good
faith say we'll set aside our
preconceptions look at the exact
language of the House articles of
impeachment the exact evidence and how
it fits
then we should recuse ourselves so Ari
that's his input on the jury selection
here of the Senate doesn't that mean
though that every twenty twenty Democrat
candidate in the Senate should also
recuse themselves I mean the former
candidates senator mcsalley suggested
it's just such a joke on its face
because what they're trying to pretend
is that they're a real court of law and
they're not if the founders want to put
this in a real court of law for a real
trial they would have done so then the
Pietschmann would have gone to her jury
it's not it's going to a political body
it was going to the house and now it's
gone to the Senate the framers would
intended it to be political because they
wanted politicians who are accountable
to the people to make these final
decisions about what you overthrow the
people's determination from an election
so stop pretending this is a court of
law if it's a court of law why are they
reading newspaper articles about it why
are they appearing on TV jurors are not
supposed to read articles about the
cases in which they're hearing so aren't
all those Democrats you're reading
newspaper stories biasing themselves no
because it's not a real trial and none
of us should look at it the way we do
and the Democrats should stop this silly
game no one's buying it Tom we also have
a situation where they are flouting this
lept harness who is an associate of
Giuliani's we're gonna interview mayor
Giuliani on Monday exclusive interview
here on the Ingraham angle we're gonna
ask more about that but partes himself
there is a bombshell it's gonna change
the whole trajectory of impeachment
really I've been calling it the gossip
girl impeachment and Parnas has more
gossip to add about things we already
know about that Rudy Giuliani was
concerned about corruption in Ukraine I
don't understand what the news is here
poor Ness is
is not providing any evidence of
impeachable acts by the President of the
United States it's interesting in a
gossip oriented way but the idea that he
has any evidence to get to provide the
Senate and that's one of the big issues
here that you told you talk about a
senator saying we have to consider the
evidence they don't have any I know so
that's why they have to throw up these
you know late hits from someone who
claims re to read the president's mind
like oh well Trump knew all about this
look how do we know we knew all about it
well I it's his guess well has anyone
checked these notes how do we know when
they were written there's no chain of
command of the note says you have to do
in a typical legal setting to
authenticate that they were written at a
certain time and they meant a certain
thing there's an entire process to go
through regarding such types of evidence
and by the way the Foreign Minister of
Ukraine had this to say re about Parnas
strangely enough my name was not
mentioned although I'm Minister of
Foreign Affairs and I frankly I never
spoke with this individual and again
frankly I don't I don't trust any word
he is now saying that deem doesn't trust
any word that he's saying you know that
what gave me so much data about watching
him in those interviews that he was
given is when people start to say
everyone's in on it you know he had to
be aware of it everyone's aware of it
and they offer no specifics so he says
the vice president was in on it the
Attorney General knew everything about
it without ever saying in a meeting on
such and so date at such and so place
the vice president was informed by such
and so total lack of specificity so it's
one of these sweeping generalization
statements that candidates make
witnesses don't because he didn't
witnessed it the specifics he has
nothing specific to provide and that
made me just shrug my shoulders and say
this is a guy who curries up to anybody
and everybody
he tells anybody and everybody what they
wanted to hear he did it with Rudy
Giuliani and now he's doing it with with
the Democrats and with their favorite TV
shows so I don't think he advanced the
ball one bit
alright gentlemen thanks so much great
to see you both tonight